yeah and would you guys care would you
get married in a courthouse no never
ever
sorry sorry okay would you get married
like a small ceremony where it's just
either like legally or just never
legally but yes most ceremonies small
ceremony yeah and I'd I'd have an
intimate wedding
like no no dress no nothing just like
we're married
well no more no more what tracks
I'm trying to think of like what the
equivalent would be but like I'm
thinking of the reason I asked the
courthouse wedding wasn't necessarily
because of like it's more intimate I was
talking about like a lot of women get
married for the wedding and not that
show of it and not for a husband and so
like if you got rid of the wedding would
you still want to get married yeah
that's a great question or money in my
pocket this is too much I think too it's
like all all of that money all that
extravagantness for maybe 20 minutes for
people to see you walk down that yes
it's beautiful yes it's great but it's
like why why all of this when you can
just show you can have the same feel
show the love that you have for the
person that you're getting married to in
a smaller aspect a cheaper aspect and
then if you all want to go have fun
afterwards go meet up somewhere it's
just a lot of weddings are very showy
and it's like do you need all that to
just say I do it's just like when you
did that video but with that black chick
when she said well how much was the
engagement 300 000 engagement 200 wow
give me a ring pop blueberry
but that's the thing it's like you're a
very used Honda Civic and you want you
want new BMW prices but if you sold
yourself at used Honda Civic prices you
might get a good buyer yeah but instead
the dating coaches are saying raise your
standards but it's like women you can't
raise your standards the older you get
like because you're less valuable in the
market and you might you might find a
sucker but do you really want a sucker
there you go I I know a crazy crazy
story
um and it kind of interlinks with
everything anyway there was this woman
um my sister knows her
um she was
I think 32 or something and um you know
she was like thinking about marriage and
things like that she didn't have anybody
she literally turned to her friend her
guy friend and said
um oh you know she was like you know uh
venting to him like oh I can't find
anyone you want to get married and he
goes I'll marry you
and they got married
she had the huge wedding like you know
the fancy dress and all that stuff and
she's still married and she doesn't love
him
and her family doesn't know and they're
waiting for grandchildren
and then and they're like why why aren't
their grandchildren
he's an idiot because he thinks that oh
yeah one day she'll fall in love with me
and she just used him literally for the
wedding is he beaten though what does
that mean smashing oh right uh I I don't
know but can you imagine she she that's
bunk bed she she's the type of person
you know she's she's a she's she's uh
you know she has a career and everything
like that she just wanted the freaking
wedding and now she's so one day she's
married him for five years she's a
narcissist isn't that nuts like I
haven't I would like I just don't care
I've never cared about a wedding but
that's how insane like they can get
about the wedding like to me like 10K at
a wedding I'm just like that's a lot of
money yeah
what can you do you see Asia for that
that's a deposit up north where you
could get a house yeah
what why did you say you would never get
married in court
well because uh
it's probably the least romantic thing
you could ever do uh because
um you know you let's just say if it
goes to divorce then the government the
state will just treat you like your two
business partners and then um you know
you would have somebody to divide your
you know your hard-earned money and your
assets so is there a way to get
married without the
courts uh yeah if you are if you're
allowed to talk about it oh yeah yeah
sure it's just uh because I think about
the US a lot and then I think about the
UK and obviously it's different but um
so in the US unfortunately and my heart
goes out to you know the men if you
cohabit they treat you as if you are you
know married in some sense you know in
terms of the woman can say you know I
want alimony I want but they weren't
even married you didn't have a marriage
contract so what is this
um because a lot of people will cohabit
not to go into that so if the woman so
then you can like amicably you know like
okay this is how much you're taking and
um she can even say yeah yeah I'll do
that but then she just goes to the
courthouse
and then they treat it as a marriage so
your your assets will be divided as if
you're married
however in the UK now uh you could uh
cohabit common law marriage as it's as
known it's not recognized as a state
marriage so that's actually something
that we need to protect in the in the UK
but you know that the the women they're
like no we want we want like a religious
ceremony
um to be the same as a state like
marriage
why why why why would they want that
security insurance
policy so what are you saying I need to
know this information hold on let me get
this straight so you see him in the
years
so if you get said in the UK yeah like I
I can cohabit with a woman and then if
we break she can't ask for nothing yeah
and unless unless unless and it's this
makes sense unless you have a child and
then you know you have yeah but that's
always sticky if you have a child yeah I
know but I just want to make that
because people probably think that
they'll just get confused but that's
what something that has to be protected
and I really wish that the US had this
um
like the cohabitation thing like just
mashing them together as if you're
married you're you know synonymous is
very wrong of course
um and we have that in the UK that's
something to be happy about that is
protected so a man an adult man an adult
woman they can negotiate media together
and you know come up with something by
themselves instead of having like a
completely foreign third party just
start dictating yeah and that's actually
worse for the children see mummy and
daddy fighting and all that stuff is
horrible but like I said it's under
threat at the moment because there are
loads of organizations and
you know like yeah anyway
um led by women
um and uh saying that no if you get a
religious ceremony let's just say so
it's not state
you it would just automatically be seen
at the State marriage and and they say
there's there's one organization I don't
know if I can mention it so I won't
mention it but they say in the website
it's like
um because we have seen
um too many women being taken advantage
of but what does that
means women that's gas yeah women have
been taken advantage of yeah
because it's cheaper to keep her because
no I think it's because they they see if
it was a state marriage you'll be closer
to getting 50 right uh and if it's like
Amic Liberty it's like okay what what
did you contribute to the marriage and
usually it will be much less than what
the man contributed because he fulfilled
the the fundamental needs
um and I'm not like downplaying what a
woman brings but in terms of them kind
of you know deciding who takes what it's
a lot it's a lot more fair but the thing
is
um equality doesn't mean I think now the
families are trying to say equity which
is quite sneaky like Equity what was the
difference oh did you want did you want
to try me I heard someone say that I
think it was yesterday or something it
was on your shower so I was losing my
mind I was like no it's like it's just
basically it's basically just equality
when it benefits like let's just be do
you know what it is it's it's it's
basically
um
okay it's a quality of outcome
so they recognize that now they're
recognizing saying equality isn't isn't
enough because we'll be called out on it
because as women we aren't the same as
men we can't do as much hours and all
that stuff right so we're not equal
however I want equity which means I I'll
get the same outcome does that make
sense so if I go and that's the worst
thing I think one of your guests said
that she's she believes in equity I
don't think she knew what she was
talking about I was losing my mind she
saw a picture with like boxes and
looking over a fence yeah I don't and
and she mentioned that individuals
that's not a good analogy yeah because
thing is literally all I can say is who
gives her the boxes
where did the boxes come from the man
yeah it doesn't make it fair yeah so as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible